I think many of you are going to enjoy this
one, even if it is horrifying.
So a few weeks ago, Sean Hannity hosted Donald
Trump in a big town hall.
They made a big deal out of it.
People in the crowd were allowed to ask questions.
It was setup as a complete softball just to
make Donald Trump look good.
And he looked terrible.
The questions were were super simple questions.
We covered this and it was notable because
even easy questions from failed on, he was
asked questions like, what were your biggest
accomplishments in your first term?
What is on your priority list for your second
term?
And Trump failed on every single one of these
softball questions.
Now, just as a reminder, here is Trump asked,
what are your top second term priorities?
He couldn't name anything.
This was a couple weeks ago.
If you hear in one hundred and thirty one
days from now, at some point in the night
or early morning, we can now project Donald
J.
Trump has been reelected, the 44th president
of the United States.
Let's talk about it.
What's at stake in this election as you compare
and contrast?
And what is one of your top priority items
for a second term?
Well, one of the things that will be really
great.
You know, the word experience is still good.
I always say talent is more important than
experience.
I've always said that.
But the word experience is a very important
word.
It's in a very important meeting.
I never did this before.
I never slept over in Washington.
I was in Washington, I think 17 times.
All of a sudden I'm president of the United
States.
You know, the story of riding down Pennsylvania
Avenue with our first lady.
And I say, this is great, but I didn't know
very many people in Washington wasn't my thing.
I was from Manhattan, from New York.
Now I know everybody and I have great people
in the administration.
You make some mistakes like, you know, an
idiot like Bolton.
All you want to do is drop bombs on everybody.
You I have to drop bombs on everybody.
You have to kill people.
Sometimes you have John Bolton, in fact, released
classified material.
Should he be prosecuted?
Oh, absolutely.
Well, he did release classified while Trump
was given another chance in another softball
Sean Hannity interview a few days ago.
And he was asked the same question and he
had weeks to prepare a better answer and he
still failed.
Trump was told by Hannity during the interview,
you know, a lot of people didn't like your
answer last time.
What are your second term priorities?
And Trump goes on for two minutes and says
almost nothing again.
He got the test again.
He already had the test questions.
He answered one way he gets the same test
again and he fails.
Take a look.
Let's.
What is your second term agenda?
Well, first of all, I didn't I was criticized
for that answer because it's a simple question.
First of all, going to defeat the the invisible
enemy.
And that's that we're wellat our way.
And as again, I told you, the mortality rate
is ten fold down.
We're going to rebuild the economy.
We're going to bring back jobs from all of
these foreign lands that have stolen our jobs
or horrible trade deals.
We're going to continue to make great trade
deals.
We're going to finish rebuilding our wall.
We're going to finish we're going to have
that.
It's going to be almost complete by the end
of this year.
Shortly thereafter, it's finished.
It's made a tremendous difference.
You see, we're doing record numbers on the
border.
Very few people are able to get through.
We're rebuilding with our military.
We've rebuilt the military 2.5 trillion dollars.
We're fixing up the V.A. for our vets.
What the job we've done there between choice
and accountability, we have choice where they
have where they can go to get a doctor.
If they're sick, they don't have to wait for
five weeks, six weeks, two weeks.
So we're doing great with the vets.
And the vets are loving Trump.
We're protecting our Second Amendment.
So important.
We need more judges and more justices.
You see that now with the Supreme Court more
than ever and the next president.
I've had to.
And the next president is going to be able
to pick two or three or one or whatever, but
a lot of justices.
And that means everything, whether it's for
life or other things.
I mean, it's been so much.
But protecting the Second Amendment.
Getting more judges, all of the things that
we've done.
Nobody has done what this administration has
done in the first three and a half years.
Nobody's even come close.
When you look at everything that we've done
now, what we're doing is working on lowering
drug prices and knocking out special interest
because it's not easy.
We're fighting for choice.
We did it for the veterans and now we're doing
it for school, too.
We're one choice in school so a parent can
take their child to a school of their choice.
And that's happening very good.
Very, very well.
And we have many things that we're doing and
many things that we've already completed.
And you can't do more than what we've done.
I think we've set records on every we actually
set a record on judges.
We're going to be by the time of the end of
this year, we'll be up to almost.
Three hundred.
So go through the list of what Trump said.
He says, My priority is to defeat coronavirus.
We've had one of the worst responses in the
world.
And when it's defeated, ultimately, it'll
have nothing to do with Donald Trump.
It will be because of medical science.
He says he's going to rebuild the economy.
It's vague and meaningless.
That's a vague and meaningless promise.
He says he's going to bring jobs back from
places that stole them.
I thought he already dealt with fixing trade
with his tariffs and USMC.
He's saying, oh, so he hasn't actually done
that.
So he's going to build the wall and that it'll
be almost complete within the year.
That's a lie.
And remember, he promised to build the full
U.S. Mexico border wall during the first term.
Obviously, it's not going to happen.
Obviously, it wouldn't happen during a second
term.
He again brings up we're going to rebuild
the military.
The military is huge.
The military's fine.
The military was fine under Barack Obama.
There's no problem with the military.
He again says he's going to keep fixing the
V.A. for veterans like with Veterans Choice.
That was an Obama provision.
That's an Obama Obama program from 2014, which
Trump is taking credit for.
But he said that he did that in the first
term.
Isn't it?
Aren't we done doing that?
So that's incoherent.
Says he's going to protect guns.
He mentions that twice.
He's done nothing as far as that goes, says
he's going to lower drug prices and kick out
the special interests.
That sounds great.
The problem is he promised that four term
one and did the opposite.
He says school choice.
That's terrible.
And it's code for take funding away from from
public education.
And then again, he mentions judges three times.
Now, that's a reason to remove Trump and to
take control of the Senate back from Republicans.
But getting judges confirmed, the Senate does
that.
It's Mitch McConnell who did that, no matter
which a Republican president you had as vacancies
come up.
They nominate people.
It's up to the Senate to go ahead and confirm
them.
So if your second term agenda is the same
vague stuff as what you did in the first term
or claimed you were going to do, but failed.
Why do you deserve a second term?
It's another one of these vapid word salads.
And I actually listen, I worry.
I know that part of the problem is that a
lot of voters hear that two minute clip and
they think Trump outlined an agenda like this
is an educational problem.
An agenda would be Trump saying or, you know,
a candidate saying, I have detailed proposals
on my Web site.
But to sum up, some of my main priorities
for the second term are in the next four years,
I want to establish a public health care option
and drop the Medicare age to 55.
I will be establishing three new tax brackets
at 40 to 45 and 48 percent.
The money which comes from that will be used
to do green infrastructure spending.
The details of which I specifically outline
on my Web site in a proposal.
But it includes retrofitting all government
buildings to certain standards.
It includes increasing the number, the percentage
of energy that we use to be generated from
these three renewables or whatever.
Right.
Will put us back in Paris climate and the
WHL.
That's something that sounds like an agenda.
What Trump said is not anything.
And one of the real problems is.
I don't want to say people are stupid, but
there's a lot of stupid people, and when I
did a set a segment just saying we've got
to realize a lot of people are stupid.
Many people don't realize that Trump didn't
even outline an agenda like that.
The problem is a lot of folks are evaluating
what Trump said to say.
Do I like this agenda or don't don't I like
it?
He didn't outline an agenda.
And a lot of Trump's followers don't realize
that it's an educational
issue
at its core.